hey everyone welcome to the world air
podcast i'm james marshall and yes this
is going to be
the last episode of season one thanks to
everyone who's tuned into one episode or
any amount of episodes this season
really enjoyed bringing them to you
caught up with heaps of awesome lads and
it's been awesome to hear some of the
big dogs be themselves for you guys so
um really enjoyed doing it and yeah
thanks for listening
a quick shout out to our three main
sponsors who have helped bring
this episode to you fortune favors
puresport cbd
and manscape so stay tuned to the end of
this episode
um to see how you can get involved with
any of these three great products
but let's get into it with this being
the last episode of season one all
series need a good finale
i knew i needed to go big not big in
size but big and lad
so i'm extremely excited to have one of
the best lads in the game voted by his
peers
he's had a hell of a journey which has
seen him play for otago
waikato hawke's bay the chiefs new
zealand maldives and now he's at the
very top of the game with the abs
it is champion lad brad weber thanks for
coming on webby
what a hell of an intro jimmy martin
that's i think the best one i've ever
had thanks
mate oh she's made the top of the list
already that's good stuff
but how's iso i know you've been pretty
busy
a lot of people have been um keeping up
with your antics um how have you found
us it looks like you're loving it
i've actually had a hell of a time yeah
i've been sweet
hearing about all the horror stories i
haven't um had any of those yet so
i've had plenty of fun on my own yeah
what have you been up to what's been
keeping
you busy um
well other than checking the chicken
[Laughter]
now i've been uh
i've been reading that i've been uh
watching netflix
yeah and um of uh i'm
trying to learn how to dj at the moment
so that's keeping me real busy
yeah i saw you doing a bit of djing in
your um clip so
have you done a bit of djing before or
is this is this something that you want
to sort of pursue is this sort of on the
off-the-cuff
now you're into it not really i um
i had done bugger all of it really i
bought a controller a couple years ago
and we just get it out at like house
parties with the boys and stuff just to
have a play around but i've got no real
idea what i'm doing
yeah and since that video was released
um george if him challenged me to do a
10 minute hot steam
live on air next week so i'm absolutely
[ __ ] myself that i have to do that
so i've been spending the last like
three or four days
constantly on it trying to learn i've
watched that many youtube videos
[ __ ] yeah i'll be more nervous than any
any footy game i've ever played
have you have you got your set sort of
plan
so i've i think i've narrowed it down to
about five songs that i'm just gonna
smash over these next or three days and
try and memorize exactly where it goes
and hope
hope that it sounds shimmy decent
and it's the dream to pursue um the dj
career
oh absolutely not
it is to be fair it has been quite fun
but yeah
i'm just not really um musically
talented enough
um i'd like i'd like to get good enough
that i could play play for my mate to
the house party or something like that
that'd be all right
i'm a much better suited just being a
punter out in the crowd
you're well known for your rnv how many
times have you been
so i've been nine times so this is going
again this year and it'll be my 10th
time so extreme veteran but
to be fair like we growing up in hawke's
bay that was like the
that was the natural thing to do is just
go to our events only just up the road
so
yeah that covers a few but i do love it
rmv legend
[Laughter]
and what have you been doing uh to keep
yourself fit
uh they gave us a what like each so i've
been jumping on that a fair bit and a
few
circuits in that because [ __ ] man
what bikes just don't sit well with me
man i'm not that strong
exactly yeah
ultimate battler just can't push the
thing fast enough so
yeah i've been struggling yeah and they
always give you like targets and stuff
and i don't know
if you're like anything like me just so
far off the target you're like
just send me a new target it's like um
you know rogue off i was like
every time i ever had to do that i was
like [ __ ] what's my handicap
am i [ __ ] 18. because i'm done i'm
like nearly double bogeying giving you
every single dog yeah rogolf's a shocker
too
oh and a little bit of acting
um you've been doing with your social
media is that is that a bit of a past
time you look pretty comfortable
acting ah that's not a
pastime sure i've just been i've just
had that much time on my hands there i
was able to take a thousand that took me
a whole day to
do that many likes you know chasing
perfection like if you saw my first date
and you're a big uh happy gilmore fan uh
you've always um
you're always referencing happy girl
more so it was good to sort of
perfect uh a scene from there yeah any
any sort of early adam sandler on on big
on
sort of billy madison yeah big daddy
you're happy gilmore's just because i
said like
danny like gareth evans and him and i
watched
um we stayed behind it uh
in our first year at uni down in dunedin
mitsubishi to break everyone goes home
but me and gareth had to stay for the
rugby so we just sat
in our movie room in our um in our hall
and watch happy gilmore like every
single day for two weeks
yeah we just like anything at training
if anything we see there's
any sort of reference to happy we'll
just
thank you mckenzie too big jim loves big
jim loves
uh happy girls but it's nice having
someone have chiefs in here they're like
bounce off too
oh that's good stuff and let's get to
the rugby house uh how's the all black
campaign how's the
how's the tour to australia being for
you
that's been good it was like a nice six
week holiday
um holding a few tackle bags and
getting paid it was all good um but no
it is
i i still enjoy myself here it's it's
great the lads are the
lads of uh are bloody good and uh we
have a lot of fun
off the field having that bye week
certainly helped too we played a fair
bit of golf with the boys so
yeah um yeah there's a lot of fun
laughter and amongst a few games
yeah so yeah not obviously not a huge
amount of game time but a couple a
couple of sharp cameos off the bench
do you find that frustrating or you're
pretty um do you feel quite settled
behind the other two
um like it's
it's hard with those two because they've
had such a monopoly on the nine spot
for you know seven or eight years now
yeah i guess
a lot more but i know selection's not
it's not my that's not my job i don't i
don't select the team so
um i just try and do my my best with the
opportunities i get but
um you know just focus on on my
uh my performance and if i'm good enough
to get selected
one day then that'll happen but yeah i
just
i don't i don't worry too much like yeah
yeah
yeah so what what's the relationship
between you three like
it's actually really good yeah like um
nagi and i are um golf partners for
while we're on tour so we uh we get
along really well and then tj and i've
had a lot of history we've
known each other since since high school
and been battling out for a long time
and
um him and i both get along bloody well
actually so
yeah yeah it actually works really good
that's good and it must still be a
pretty surreal feeling for you
coming from where you have to to be in
the all blacks it still
sort of must be like a pinch yourself
moments now and again even though you're
not
probably getting the game time that you
probably want um just to be in the
environment still must be a pretty
surreal feeling
oh [ __ ] yeah like yeah
especially from where i came from and
like you know i was never
i would have never been someone that was
touted to ever be at all black so
yeah i had a bit of luck and um a bit of
good fortune going my way as well but
uh worked pretty hard to get there too
so it's it's nice to have a lot of that
stuff sort of pay off
yeah for sure well let's get back let's
get to your journey let's start at the
start
um let's go back to when a very young
baby
brad mccormick webber was born
i guess right there right there oh it
was napier hospital i remember it really
well
it was the first thing you saw
oh my dad probably fainting or something
i would say
devastated that is just burnt down
um
that's where that's where me and gareth
um
met and yeah became pretty um we decided
to
follow each other around the country
where we could really so
yeah plenty good times there man yeah i
bet um
and rugby when did you start your rugby
uh
pretty straight away like so dad and my
granddad both played
halfback for hawksbayer so oh yeah um i
was always
as much as i tried not to
be a halfback or i knew eventually it
was always going to catch up to me
i tried everything else i think i played
like 12
under 15s and then 15. yeah
and then 15 i was and then 15 at um my
first
10 and 15 for my first couple of years
uh first fifteen and then my last year
uh i went i built the bullet and went
into half back but
so were you quite a big guy to be at 12.
no i wasn't so for under 50 under 15s
that year i think i was um
because i was young for my year so i
could go down so i
i was probably similar size well not i
wasn't big but
[ __ ] i should just like do the classic
anton leonard brown like get the ball
and then step back like five times
i wasn't very good
[Laughter]
but i played the position
[Laughter]
so that's a late start to go to nine
though um
did you have a good pass and stuff yeah
i always
i always had a pretty good part like i
would while i was playing fifteen
and ten like i would cover nine as well
so i was always
yeah and i yeah i'd always um
yeah i'd always practice it anyway so
because i knew i'd deep down i knew
if you look at my dad and like all my
family like there was only one position
i was ever going to go so
i was just trying to have fun while i
could and were you a bit of a
schoolboy star no not really like
um i didn't make the new zealand schools
team or anything i think
i made the hurricane schools in my last
year
i was behind tj yeah but we had a good
side though like
no one made new zealand schools but um
we made top four we beat a star started
like one
college team to make top four who
everyone thought they were going to win
the whole thing so
yeah we were just a team of team of
absolute battlers that
punched above their weight so yeah it
was pretty cool like high west was
our 10 so we had a pretty good game
driver and gareth was at eight
and i was at nine so we left what a
spine
yeah exactly
so then how did you how did you go on to
making the new zealand 20s which was
probably the most stacked new zealand
20s
to ever be named i reckon how did you go
from
missing out on these teams to making
that team
so i went to um i went down to donald's
to study
and my first year played tiger 19s and
then got
made the new zealand under 20 uh
with the big squad that they they have
for the camps yeah and i remember
i remember the catch up with the guy i
don't know who it was he was like
telling me like yep you're in
um there's four out of the halfbacks or
whatever and he was basically telling me
that i've
probably don't have much of a chance
because i was the last ranked half that
going into it i was like oh yeah yeah
whatever yeah and then gone up there and
played
really well in all the trolls and and
ended up making the team so
that's basically how happens i went from
obviously last ranked and then me and tj
were the nines that went to the world
cup and
yeah like you say stat team yeah like i
think there's like 13 all blacks or
something is that advice
that's great he's got a long way to get
them beaten yeah yeah
who are the other two nines you overturn
uh
um papa faraway who was
in school he was in new zealand school's
captain so he had a lot of pedigree and
then
um lucky palamo uh a guy from counties
who was
raw and had a lot of talent ability yeah
um but i think they just i remember just
going into the trials and just like
focusing on just getting to the right
quickly and distributing and they seem
to
like it so it's certainly helped ever
since too
so how many times throughout your career
have you been told you were
too small it must have happened a fair
bit
yeah it's happened a lot like heaps but
particularly i remember two professional
coaches
have said it to me oh yeah won't have
any names but even at that level
yeah like one at mitre 10 cup and then
um
another uh
in another area but yeah they both both
said then i was
to be fair at the time it might have
been true because like the halfbacks
then were quite big like it was like
jimmy cowan and
big guys you know so like at the time
that's the sort of halfback they were
after but
um thank god for like the way the games
sort of
transitioned and then when nagi made it
um that certainly helped my cause
that was the the type of mould that a
lot of teams are after and that's sort
of when things started happening for me
yeah sure that's good and then um so you
went down to dunedin you said
for uni um got stuck into the club rugby
scene down there
how was that oh mate honestly
best four years of my life was was down
in denature just
being straight in and playing rugby on
the side pretty much and yeah
was that the dunedin sharks rugby club
down there
fantastic off yeah so the original fins
up
and and so [ __ ]
honestly so many people ask me these
days like why do you put the marco for
now
yeah dunedin club since like the 1800s
everyone just here says claims that
you're a marker yeah
yeah but man that culture out there was
so good like
one year we had five colts teams so
every
every said you're guaranteed to have you
know like nearly
just sort of 60 80 students out there
just absolutely
club rooms epic so we had a lot of fun
um one one pub championship and um
yeah the student lifestyle man down
there is just like it's hard to
hard to describe because like the city
is just so built around the uni
like you know the city center is just
all the uni area so
everything's walkable you're guaranteed
to find someone that's keen to drink
with you on
any night if you if you want to like
like gareth and i because gareth and i
lived on castle street in second year
yeah in fact it was just like it was
carnage man like
i remember going into like going into
one of my mates flats at the beehive and
they just had
literally like a bonfire just happening
in the middle of the lounge
not in like abrasion or anything but
just literally something's
burning in the middle
just some of the best times then how
often would you be going out a week you
know how you said that
you could twist someone's arm every day
of the week how often would you be going
out
the first year you'd probably be going
out well particularly
with rugby it'd be like twice a week so
you may maybe do like a thursday and
then
saturday night yeah um but i tried we
gareth and i tried to be a bit more
serious and second year onwards and only
did saturday nights but
it was certainly certainly blokes i knew
there's certainly blokes hungry that did
a lot more than twice a week but
um yeah one guy actually one guy
that we gareth and i lived with them on
castle street
he was like absolute legend of a bloke
like
in our um a week so
seven seven days usually going he just
instead of going and buying a whole heap
of beers from the bottle store he just
went and bought himself a keg and just
had it for himself for the week
[Laughter]
one but one of the nights he forgot to
take the pump off so the next day it
just tastes like absolute
cactus and he had to drink that for the
rest of the week
yeah he's still winning it like he's an
absolute champion but
as um the light has
sort of korean as unique he ended up
dropping out
and went to went back home to hawke's
play we knew from there and his family
owned a lot of orchards
and he's kind of like well you know what
am i going to do with my life
or would i have an abundance of a whole
heap of apples
what do i love doing pissing up so he
created his own cider company
and it has blown up like it is massive
right
he's completely killing it so just like
he's not
he's not alcoholic but just absolutely
frosted and he yeah and he
owns a big side of the company in
hooke's bay now so that's awesome done
pretty good
do what you love i love what you do
[Laughter]
also how did you get into the rugby
scene down there then obviously playing
club rugby must have been playing well
so then did you get a taste of the otago
uh npc side yeah so 2012 i've
had a pretty good club season with with
the sharks and made the otago score of
that year i think i only played nine
games all off the bench and didn't get a
hell of a lot of minutes but
um it was a good introduction to the
stuff fumiyaki tanaka was the nine
um brownie he brought him over from
japan and he was he's
clearly pretty [ __ ] up so smaller than
you though yeah a lot smaller
yeah but inspiring and
and talking about lads like that
ultimate japanese lad like
is it on the purse it's just
some of the stuff he does is just can i
could harvey speak a
lick of english when he's sober but [ __ ]
once he has a few beers he's almost
fluent
oh that's good stuff yeah
so um yeah not too many opportunities
and
now i got i've actually got dropped the
next year so um it was a
roller coaster ride down in dunnis but
yeah so how'd you get dropped
talk me through that so the first sort
of half of the club season in
um 2013 i i wasn't i wasn't going that
good
um and they there's a young kid out of a
target boy who was pretty sharp
i had a lot of reps on them josh renton
um so he was especially out of school
and i remember i got brought into um
office
at otago um halfway through with brownie
and
um phil young the coaches at the time
and i was like oh [ __ ] maybe they're
offering me a contract for the year
and that was the opposite way they like
told me that uh
released to me from the target training
squad and sure
okay like but
to be fair at the time like it was the
kick up the ass that i needed like
i wasn't really working that hard on my
course skills outside of actual team
training like i was just doing the bare
minimum
yeah thinking that like just by getting
older i'd get better you know
yeah and that they sort of made me
realize that what i was doing wasn't
enough so after that
i started like massively smashing my um
my core skills and
back after that club season i was like
is the best club season i'd had like i
was
i think i was club player of the year at
least for the sharks anyway we won the
club com
but i still was i still wasn't good
enough to make the the final squad so i
josh and um furmyaki with the nines that
year so
i just played a couple of games of um
targo b and i was just thinking yeah
sorry i'll just see out my
my degree and then see what happens but
then i got a call from tom coventry and
he was
the assistant coach of the chiefs at the
time and he was like oh with
brendan leonard's leaving um he's going
overseas we've got a spot for our third
halfback i was like well
i was sitting in the library in otago
uni i was like i've been dropped from
their target team tom on
like how are you guys going to get me to
uh how are you guys going to watch me
and he was like oh if we can you know
maybe
sort something out would you be willing
to move and i was like yeah hell yeah if
i get an opportunity and
a couple days later what killer coach
rang me up and asked me to move up there
so
i've been in hamilton ever since so the
chiefs actually got you
a npc
then and trent renata the party starter
definitely um
because i played that club so i
played that club yes i played that club
season that year with
trent at the sharks because he was with
the landers and he was released all the
time to play with us
so i played a lot with him that yeah and
he um and because i played so well
he went to the waikato coach because he
was playing for waikiki at the time
and was like you need to bring this guy
up like he's he's good um
he's missed out on the otago team so
then when the chiefs then said the same
he was like okay yeah
i'll do it so a lot to train yeah party
started
career started he started he started my
career
[Laughter]
so yeah so yeah that's what and like
first week i think i come off the bench
against south and then the week after
um they gave me a start against auckland
we won the game and i just did like the
game of my life i think i was playing i
was barking against um pippy whipper and
scored two trys and wow
offered me a chiefs contract so like
within two weeks
i got from just sitting in the library
being a student playing a target b
yeah and then getting a huge contract
was like [ __ ] this is just unbelievable
so that's mad eh yeah yeah and dave
actually came around to your house
yep i was i was staying at um kid
louie's house at
robbie robinson's place yeah with um
brayden mitchell with scratcher
oh that's great great man absolute great
man the like
but we had we had some [ __ ]
and um and yeah wren's literally he
he rang me um that morning was like
where would he live
and i was told him and then he turned up
like an hour later
far out unreal yeah so then how how was
um how was it going into that chiefs
team
it was like it was way better than i
expected because when i when i was going
in i was like right
leave me some aaron critten all these
guys i was like [ __ ] i'm not gonna say
anything well i'm just gonna keep my
head down and but as soon as i walked in
they all like
made me feel real comfortable um
i remember leah mason was like basically
that's one of the first things he said
to me is like you got a chance to be my
new favorite white boy
i reckon i was like yo
[Laughter]
i think you could just watch like um the
waikato stuff so i was like
it's like my first day like a little kid
a little little third form of a seventh
former talking dog
[Laughter]
so um
did you become his favorite well i think
behind
behind the beaver maybe it might be
might be right
up there oh you take that set well
because
i reckon the reason why i maybe got over
the line and i remind them of this
um quite often is that when you play
your first game for the chiefs
you do three um waco drafts after that
and
in the team room afterwards we were to
bring our three bears and before we did
it
uh liam was like well we're the first to
and you'll be my favorite white boy so i
did
and then as i'm doing the third one jlo
is like spewing in the bucket
all i fall over
the lads just loved it
[Laughter]
would have been filthy he was devastated
i just ruined his knife
so yeah i think i might have just snuck
in um
and did you get many did you get many
games um that first year
no i think i only played i think i
played like seven games
all off the bench just when um or
augustine were
um weren't available so those two were
um
the main stairs and are pretty good i
think all you matters all that they do
the end of your tour so
behind two blacks at the time but yeah
that was cool man
yeah i knew i knew i i think i knew then
that like
i'd found like my team like the place
that i wanted to be like
yeah everywhere else just didn't like
with all due respect to otago like it
just wasn't
like the team just didn't suit my style
of playing like
yeah brownie really wanted knew what he
wanted in his nines he wanted guys that
just
passed and kicked really well whereas i
was at the time probably more of a
running
nine um
and the chief suited me in there in that
area
and then yeah going back to the waikato
side were you did you become captain
that following year yeah so i
yeah it's one thing that i was yeah at
the time
uh i think i was 23
and i've only played seven games for
walking though and then
um yeah johnny walters asked asked me to
be the captain and i was like
i wasn't too keen because he he'd clear
he cleared out a lot of the
senior guys like guys that i really
liked and respected including
trent which which really hit like kind
of hurt me actually because
trent was part of the reason that i got
up to waikiki and then for him to get
rid of him like that
yeah i really didn't didn't like but
but when i like looked around the squad
we were just it was just a whole bunch
of babies really so
um yeah i accepted the the job and um
like pretty much an under 21s team yeah
talented group though
it was a real talented group that real
raw and i yeah we were playing them a
couple of times how did you guys go that
season
i think uh well we didn't get relegated
so that was a success
um for a lot of us because if you look
back at the squad now like
unreal like damian at 10 anton shawn
stevenson
fethu douglas like all these awesome
players but at the time
back were just babies like 18 19 so we
got two
lists i think we put might have played
um you guys maybe
second round you guys uh i mean tasman
and
you might have been at the neck at the
time actually um
and guys gave us a bit of a toweling up
so that was a real um
reality check for a lot of a lot of our
boys and how did you find it as captain
um it was pretty eye-opening like i
leant a lot on
some of the senior guys like josh hondak
and um
guys like that just to help out because
i wouldn't
say i'm like a natural um
like i i enjoy public speaking and that
but in terms of like around the team
like
i like to i don't like to talk for the
sake of it like i
really like to speak when i feel like
i've got something decent to say and
yeah
i'm still only 23 and not exactly
experienced so
um it was definitely a team effort and
then i just sort of ran the ball out
on saturday ran the ball down and did
the media
yeah and you were good at it
yeah i don't i don't mind talking [ __ ]
to the media so that definitely
so then you ended up getting an all
black debut down the line so how did
that come about
yes so uh on the india i think india
tour of 2014
um tourist acl so from there i knew i
was
uh going to get more game time with the
chiefs it's just me in orgy so
yeah ended up playing playing a fair bit
i think i shared um
sort of similar amount of stats his
augie and
um yeah like one thing led to another
and then i got
um named in the squad to play that
uh test against samoa over there and
like
at that time i was just like [ __ ] what's
what's going
on like yeah actually i remember um
i remember getting the call from shandy
and we were on our we've lost to the
hollanders i think in the quarter final
the
that weekend and we're on the saw
somewhere and
shandy was like oh you're going to be
brought into the um to your blacks team
um for the squad against
uh sam i was like oh awesome and i must
have sounded heavy things like so it
might be a good idea to put the beers
down
and ready for camp so i was like yeah
right oh i put it down told the boys and
just charged
i had to celebrate
oh were you expecting it at all or did
it come did that come completely out of
the blue
they've been kind of like whispers about
it that i was sort of in the
in the running but um the squad had been
named and it was targeted tj and
and aaron um
and then like andy ellis was still
around and so i was like guards
and it's a world cup year so they're not
going to take a chance on a 24 year old
who hasn't played so i didn't think that
year was going to be it but then yeah
when things all started happening and
i've got the call up
was that [ __ ] this is unreal man that
was so that would have been like two
years
from getting dropped from otago to
playing for the all blacks
[Music]
inspirational and you pretty much put
that down to
just changing your habits um working
harder
outside of training and things like that
is that what you put it down to yeah
yeah absolutely like it was
i had zero work ethic um outside of
training
um when i was with the otago team and
brownie
um helped me realize that so
while he you know while he dropped me
from the squad i actually owe him a lot
because
um yeah he sort of helped change my mind
see along with a couple other guys that
um
that helped me out um once that happened
so yeah definitely just change
change my my mindset to um
to my craft and start working a little
bit harder and doing more of my own
rather than just relying on
coaches and set training times really
because yeah
yeah that's i realized that's what i
needed to do if i wanted to
be a professional inspiring stuff so
then let's go to your all black debut it
must have been pretty um
daunting going into that squad i mean it
was a pretty stacked side world cup yeah
um talk me through that yeah it was
it was pretty daunting i wasn't like
walking into my first meeting and like
richie and dan
and all those guys were all there i'm
like and i'm just this
so at the time i'm thinking like i'm
just like the scarfy like this
[Laughter]
he just managed to manage to make his
way in here
um but i was real keen to like just
just enjoy it and like for what it was i
remember i ruined with dan
um in auckland and um that was pretty
cool like
for me just to just alive and just chat
to him around
um all this like all the stuff around
the game plan and just chat in general
so
that was yeah it was cool but um
yeah the actual debut i remember it was
like
nearly 100 humidity and 34 degrees it
was that like
didn't even need to warm up or sitting
on the bench just sweating
got like um got the last sort of
16 or 17 minutes or something and it was
absolutely blowing at the end too like
i'm pretty
pretty sure i'm pretty sure i missed
like the last two rucks because i was
just that [ __ ]
probably wasn't a good uh probably
wasn't a good audition but
um but i made the debut and dad came
over for it
um him and his brother came over for it
so it was pretty cool
and how did you go at the haka because
you've got a bit of maori in you which a
lot of people don't realize but
um you're one of the only all black
knights who hasn't led the hacker at the
moment so
[Laughter]
any plans and how was your first one
um my first one was all right i don't
think i stuffed it up
um but i'm pretty sure i was i'm pretty
sure i didn't really
like belt out too many of the words
because i was just so focused on the
actions like not stepping it up
but i'm much better now like i'll tell
you like having a few years with with
the maori all blacks
makes a big difference on your haka like
yeah you're forced
to learn and get pretty good and that
that hype is pretty cool so
um you definitely get better um but
no i was actually i actually had um
a little bit of an idea for um
for the all black stuff i was going to
do but i didn't didn't end up doing i
couldn't do it
in another year but i was thinking like
having like a microphone um attached to
me and like
someone in the distance like following
along with the camera and me going up to
like sam and
sam kane and like tj maybe fuzzy be like
oh
look i've been putting a lot of thought
into it i really can't leave the hacker
[Laughter]
and my microphone and see what their
reactions are
oh that sounds good it sounds like good
watermelon maybe you should call it
record it for me
a lot of people were actually asking me
when i think it was the argentina game
when
it was like tj wasn't in the in the
match day 23 and
um like who's going to leave the hakka
you might be
he might be a chance yeah seem like
but i'll just um i'll just stick to the
middle of the pack
yeah fair enough and then um after that
test was that just you just played the
one test was it
yeah yeah so um after that um nag and tj
was joining the squad so i dropped down
and
um played a game for the maldives and
then went back to
waikato for my last season with them
and that was a good season very good
what happened um
so similar to him like all the same lads
and then actually beaver came back from
japan
and at the time i remember um
i remember our coach brought me into to
the office
and was like i was like [ __ ] what have i
done like did i do something and
he's just like oh i just want to let you
know that um that stephen donald's
reached out and he's going to come back
from japan and join the squad and i
remember just
bursting out laughing i was like
because at the time beaver was like you
know the god
yeah the movie star yeah the move the
kicking just came out
and you know i was like oh and we were
just all these young fellows and then
all of a sudden the babe comes back this
is awesome but he was great like he was
so good for
damien especially and um a few other
blokes and we had a hell of a time like
uh with him and then um our last game we
we've been up and down had a few good
wins a couple of horrific losses
and then um our last game of the season
was against hawke's bay
who had the shield and they'd had it for
like nearly two years so they
a real strong squad good experience
super
experience everywhere and we're just saw
this bunch of young kids yeah and i
remember
we had this because we were going so
[ __ ] we had this like team meeting
on like the monday or whatever and um
one of our coaches was like
showing clips of the hawke's bay team
he's like look how good they are
look oh
[Laughter]
and like we had all almost like these
heart the hearts um
around our game plan and stuff like a
few guys like came at each other and
we're
just like right [ __ ] it this this week
we can basically just do whatever you
want like guys go
where you want just play what's in front
of you and i remember hold josh honey
was like
so you're saying that i can go and sit
at first receiver if i want to and we're
just like yup do it
and in the game he said fish receiver i
gave
he broke he broke through and scored a
drive a little bit like
judy yeah no [ __ ]
and then we just played like a game of
our lives like antoine damien just
carved up
and i managed to score a second half
patrick and oh
no doubt
because it was the last game of the
season and we missed the semi's yeah
just won the ship and we just had the
biggest week of our lives
back to beaver's place
[Laughter]
mind blowing like all these kids and
then turning up to beeb's place they
have a beard
but then you then you like you sort of
sort of realize that thieves just like
he's one of the lads like just
legend of a bloke yeah what
happened like you know the whole success
story couldn't have happened to a better
bloke you know
yeah so good so good
and did you sign with hawkesbury at this
stage or was it after this
nice so i'd actually already signed with
them like before the season that even
started so
um yeah because like i was
saying he really dad and granddad both
played half back forks but i'd always
really wanted to be a magpie and um
gareth and ehi were
back there as well so it was just the
time was right like i
i've done i felt like i'd done enough uh
for waikato to
pay back their faith for bringing me up
from otago and then yeah it was just
time to go home so
yeah so i but going into that game i
knew that i was going there next year
but i wouldn't i can change it for the
world but yeah winning the shield is
like just
like you know so it's just nothing quite
like it and i still every
every promo i ever go to in hooke's bay
someone always asks like why did you
take this shield off us i was like you
have no idea what the
stuff was like
oh that's good yeah and then how did you
find going to hawke's bay going back
home
that was great like going back to
hawke's bay especially
for the time that uh miter team cups
played on it's like going on holiday
because
it's sunny it's it's mild weather like
it's not
yeah it's not cold like everywhere else
it doesn't rain a hell of a lot so it's
just to play a bit of footy especially
after a long super season
it's it's really refreshing and um and
uh it's nice being home around some of
my old mates and
yeah seeing a lot of the people that are
left behind i guess but
um and yeah getting to play with all my
schoolmates and stuff's pretty cool so
and they're at the moment they're
playing unbelievably well so it's cool
to see a lot of those young kids
homegrown kids too um playing well for
for the bay
pretty good nine there too now too away
[ __ ] yeah he is playing really good
flower he's um he's a funny little guy
like um he was he was green for a while
like
you you could always tell he had like
the more ability that the speed the
strength and everything was just about
putting the game management together and
now he's really starting to get it and
um yeah he's
uh wouldn't surprise me to see him uh
in the orbits pretty soon sure big wraps
so then later on your career hit a bit
of a
road not a crossroad but had a bit of a
block when you broke your femur do you
want to talk about that
moment yeah so
uh that was start of 2017 at that um
pre-season tens tournament in
in brisbane yeah it was like 42 degrees
we're playing in the final
and um i actually haven't watched i
haven't rewatched it but
from what i remember i had my leg
trapped by someone
and i was trying to offload the ball or
something and then i just got hit from
another
another way and it just my femur just
went back split like that
um yeah it was yeah not flash but it
look
at the time like so many people like
[ __ ] it must have hurt apparently it's
not that
you know the strongest bone in your body
and uh but i didn't really feel
anything like i was just shocked like
everything was numb and yeah
i couldn't really tell them what i'd
done like i sort of thought that
i sort of thought that my my i might
have done my knee or something because
the numbness was kind of down in that
area
um and but i looked down and like my
so my ankle was like lying like that so
my leg was like that
my ankle was falling away and i was like
that's weird i don't have any pain down
there
so i was like oh maybe i've dislocated
my knee or something but turns out when
you
split your um femur like your lower leg
is obviously not attached to anything so
just like
falls yeah so they stretched me off
and because i told them i think it was
my knee they were like doing all these
tests on my knee and stuff like
um medial everything and then to do the
acl they obviously hobbled
they like pulled the tibia away yeah
yeah
and doing so they pulled my whole lower
leg away
and i remember just feeling it and just
been like
[ __ ] don't do that okay and so the
girl's like
i think you've done your acl and your
knee and i was like
it's nine months so um
get to the uh they put me on a
on a uh wheelchair i watched the rest of
the final in that time mitch graham's
broken his tib and fib like like that so
he's
got a stretcher he's he's had the green
whistle and he's like dabbing as he's
going home
and so he so he got the ambulance to to
the uh hospital
yeah there was no ambulance left so
they're like right we need to get to the
hospital so they
put me in the front of this car and like
put my ass in first
wiggle me around and like my leg is just
too long which doesn't often happen for
me that just too long
to fit right in so they have to like
move my leg up again and
by the stage the adrenaline's were worn
off the shocks worn off and like that's
when the pain just
like screaming through but i was just
losing it they gave me a green whistle
because i was like smashing that on the
car
to the hospital but it did nothing like
i was still in pain
had they had the mri they checked my
knee
and they're like no it's sweet they're
kind of like speaking that's it's all
good i was like right my fire's like
killing me like you might want to check
that so they did and they're like
[ __ ] you yeah you've fractured your
femur
we're here to get you in like we need to
get you into surgery like
right now wow pretty much emergency
surgery like
the match doctor who like did the
testing on my knee was like
mortified that he did what he did
while i had a broken femur like because
obviously there's like
a femoral artery that runs alongside it
like he could have so easily just like
nipped it
and i would have bleeded out in minutes
so very
very very lucky that
uh it didn't end up that way that's a
rocky rocky move from the doctor
yeah i'm pretty sure he'll still get
[ __ ] about that
yeah so what's the reason okay
now i actually because we played that
game at suncor
um against australia recently and i
caught up with my surgeon there which
was quite cool to see i didn't even
mention that
he was just like i still can't believe
you [ __ ] did that
so what's the rehab like for a broken
femur are you in the cast and how long's
the
how long's the whole process it's so
it's so funny enough it was actually so
it's better than doing an acl
or actually so because so what they do
is that
and i've got i was in no cast i was up
not walking but like on a
on a walking not a wheelchair but almost
like crutches the very next day
so what they do is they like drill into
the top of your femur
and then like hammer down a big titanium
rod right down there
right down the length of it yeah two
screws two screws at the ends all i've
got
from that is like two little scars like
about that that big
for a broken femur so it's i've still
got the rod in there at the moment
and um because the bone heals
like when that with over the break it
like heals bigger so
like the bones actually stronger it
comes back stronger so
doing a fame is actually better than
doing an acl funnily enough but
um yeah and they told me six months and
you'll be back
playing so i was like [ __ ] hell like
i
thought you know a year maybe something
like that but now
the surgeon was like real positive he's
like now you'd be sweet you he's
he's pretty blush he's pretty he's a
bloody good bugger but
um yeah he's like no you'd be sweet six
months and you'll be back and
um so i was like i think it was
six weeks on crutches and then i can
start like um
start walking being a little bit better
with like less with more
more weight more weight bearing and um
that was what it was all about trying to
get the weight bearing back and then
um yeah i think i ended up taking an
extra month just to be sure so i took
seven months and i was back
playing yeah yeah and what was your
confidence like did you feel confident
around it or
yeah yeah by that stage i did um and i
had like a few tackles on it and like
got tackled and stuff
and one the first one of that was always
like
was what i was most worried about but
then when i thought about it i was like
[ __ ] i've got a metal rod
down the length of my leg there's no way
that thing's going to break
so they gave me all the confidence in
the world
so i was i was sweet once i got the
first game
i was good i did have a little bit of
issues like um the
the screw that's holding it in at the
top
was like sticking out like just a little
bit too far like my
tendon around my hip was like rubbing
over it a bit too much every time i ran
that would give me a bit of pain but i
just got that ripped out and i was
i walked out of the hospital but that
day i was like and throughout the sweet
so
um yeah it probably took me a couple
probably two years until i i felt back
to
myself like the whole 2018 while i was
back
playing i i just still wasn't quite
myself yet yeah like strength and speed
and stuff and then
yeah so i can two years for a league
break to fully
feel normal again so yeah started 29
2019s when i
felt myself again in 2019 you came into
absolute red hot form started pretty
much all the game for the chiefs and
worked your way into the uh rugby world
cup squad with the all blacks so
how was that year for you yeah it was
it was uh that was a interesting year
because
um because i took myself i pulled out of
the multiple black squad at the end of
2018 to go home a bit earlier so i could
start
so i could do the full pre-season with
the chiefs and just because in my mind i
was like right 2019's my last year of
giving it
giving navy's a crack if i don't make it
then i'm going to go to i'm going to go
overseas
yeah and um so i was like i'm going to
go
do a full preseason get as fit as i can
get and just give it
my best nudge um that was at the start
and then
one once the season came around i was
like actually you know what like i
actually don't
i don't really not that i don't care but
like i
i put it out of my mind around making
the all blacks i was kind of like well
i could play the best rugby i could be
the best player in super angry this year
and still not make the all blacks and
like
i'd be really at peace with it like i
knew that i'd done all i could
yeah up until that point so i was in a
really good place mentally around
not worrying about um about the av
stuff and just wanted to have fun with
the boys because i knew that maybe that
could be my last year so i was like [ __ ]
i'm just gonna have some fun
enjoy it and when we started off real
[ __ ]
we were horrific we lost our first five
games
everyone was like riding us off this guy
i was like oh god it's going to be one
of those years
yeah and then we just turned it around
and um
i ended up making the playoffs and
having a really good season and then
um yeah i was lucky enough to get my
name
read out for the for the eight visa it
was funny how it all sort of worked out
sure and did you just find out from the
tv like everyone else
yes i had no idea so i was um
i knew my my parents would just be like
nervous
tricks i didn't bother going home to
watch it with them
so i just stayed in my flat uh my house
in hamilton with
my two flatmates at the time abby and
beck's the two girls and
um we were all singing along and my
heart was racing man like
like i never never never fell and then
heard the name get read out and like my
two flatmates just lost a lot of
screaming and everything jumping all
over me it was quite nice actually
[Laughter]
so yeah so yeah that's how i found out
just like you run now it's quite a cool
way of doing it i reckon rather than um
yeah give me the phone call on the
diesel yeah yeah
yeah yeah go around see your hot flat
mate
two of the best ways
[Laughter]
and then how was the rugby world cup for
you
i actually i loved it like japan great
place then i could like if i was going
to play overseas
that's something i'd like to go and um
yeah like we didn't win the whole thing
which um which was a shame and
cost us a lot of money too and bonuses
but
that's what it is
[Laughter]
yeah do it all again it was a cool
experience and getting to play and
um you know i was playing some of my
best rugby at the world cup as well as
yeah and super ugly that year so i i had
a fair bit of fun yeah you got a fair
amount of time in that world captain
yeah
yeah yeah i played against the two um
against the two minnows i've played
against canada and namibia but i
um come on at half time against canada
and schooled a couple of tries and
yeah um linked linked up with tj and
then it would be a game for that
yeah yeah which was pretty cool like
i think we might have been rooming
together that year like oh that that we
can yeah when we got home we were just
like what the [ __ ] what are you doing
outrageous
so good and then what about the
disappointment after the uh england game
must have been how's the team and yeah
how are you
yeah i was um yeah like i was gutted man
but i was real yeah like i was
devastated for the boys and then and for
myself but
i didn't really uh didn't really feel it
fully until we got back into the chain
rooms and all the lads come back in and
sat down and you just see on the faces
of some of the guys especially the guys
whose last
go it was like yeah that year they were
just devastated and
that's when i you know i felt for them
more than i felt for myself
like because obviously i didn't play the
game so
you know all my influence was through
the week trying to get the boys ready
but
i'm just yeah real gutted for them like
yeah i realize i remember 2007 and being
so devastated and then
you know obviously the country hadn't
even felt that since then so
to be in the chain room and seeing it
seeing the raw emotion from some of
those guys was
yeah it's pretty good thing for them
yeah for sure and now
this year massive yeah chiefs squads
have just yeah
your team's looking pretty strong
feeling confident
yeah i am i i think uh you know
obviously we weren't
we were well we were horrific last year
[Laughter]
but a lot but we've got a lot of
continuity like not too many blokes have
left
um and a lot of those young guys that
got thrown in the deep end last year
another year older than another yearbook
so i've got a lot of confidence this
year i think will be i think will
surprise a lot of people
right up there heard it here first
include yeah including your hurricanes
boys reckon
uh and then uh what's what's what's your
plans going forward have you have you
got much of a
plan laid out you mentioned potentially
heading over to japan at some point but
um what's your what's your current
status
so i'm on contract for one more year um
and i'll just wait way up and see i
think um
i i might have to make a call for a few
months
and obviously with tj in japan this year
um he'll be back to be available for the
all blacks but
certainly gives me a little bit of a
chance to
try and play well and maybe maybe push
him
and nagi a bit a bit more than i have
but at the same time like
yeah i i if a good offer from japan or
something comes
comes along i might well um take it
um you know i gotta i'm 30 in january so
um like i don't feel old like i still
feel like i've got heaps left
yeah so i don't i really don't want to
leave um while i'm playing my best rugby
but
at the same time with an offer that's
too good to turn down comes along it's
going to be hard to
sort of say no to so we'll just wait and
see
um but yeah either way i'll try and have
a bit of fun with the lads this year
um on the off chance that it might be my
last but how much are you after i know
tj got his contract through the
um podcast he said that it was after a
body contract in japan what are you
after
a boaty contract but
i don't think i can quite demand that
but if i
sort of three quarters of that i'd be
pretty
all right we'll make that happen yeah
thanks
thanks
[Laughter]
oh what a journey [ __ ] that's good to
hear good to hear your story
sorry it's quite long isn't it no it
doesn't look now now we're into
now we've got the good part the
questions a lot of people have
jumped at the chance to ask brad webber
a question so
i'll go to the instagram page and read
out some of your questions
okay first question what is your dream
career after rugby
my dream career of rugby would be
running like a almost like a maddie
john's show
type um tv show that would be
quite cool um linking out with um
a few actually factory you'd be quite
probably
quite good on that show like that might
have to um throw you in there with like
likes of anger start about and just let
the creative juices flow like they can
go
and do let them go and do some like
creative stuff maybe i'm
i'm doing a little bit as well yeah but
um you know
maybe i'll be the facilitator i don't
know like keep keeping you and keeping
us just in check a little bit
but exactly but i'd like it to be
a bit more borderline than the current
um rugby shows that are out there i
think
um but there's obviously a place for
seriousness and stuff but
a lot of the borderline humor that uh
maddie johnson stuff
from yeah american new zealand needs a
bit of that oh
goodness yeah love the dream
okay next question are you still hitting
mass freak
the mutant mess so
i'm not not mutant mess itself but i am
on like
so on the shakes that the chiefs give us
i'm on like the big suckers the big
thousand calorie type ones but honestly
i just need that just to
maintain my weight because if i don't
i'll just drop it off
so what's newton mass what is that so
mutant mess was like
so it was the protein um like this big
ass protein bag that i got in my first
year at uni
because i was only like i don't know how
heavy i was i must have only been like
60 kilos or something
yeah and um you know i wanted to put on
weight so i could
because i've been told i was too small
and stuff like that and i
i bought this big music mess and it's
just like
thick like seriously thick shapes
that you'd make up to try and just put
on mess
and it didn't work
but i bought that i bought it anyway
oh that's good stuff okay
okay your grandad was a local legend
what rugby advice did he give you
um i wouldn't say he gave me a lot of
advice
but he um he would often ring he would
often ring me up
he was brutal in his um and his uh and
his reviews of any of my games like
he would it ring me up like most weeks
and
he'd always start off with the good
stuff he's quite good he'd start off
with the good stuff
like oh yeah your passing was good today
but yeah
like i knew where it was going yeah this
was this is okay and they'd be like
that your tackling was [ __ ] it was good
you needed a sword you've been doing
this and then i was like oh
i'll just be on the phone yep yeah okay
and that's a lot
a classic green answer he came to um it
was actually the
so he came to my last one of my last
games for
waikato my first first year when i got
brought up we played against bayer
plenty and he came up to watch
and at the after match at the after
match i was talking to someone and i
looked over and he was talking to toby
smith bird prop and he was telling
him how he should be scrumming and my
grandmother
my granddad was like a little happy he
was tiny
but he was like going on he's like you
should be doing this and that's like
blinded and i just saw toby like like
that's going what the [ __ ] is this
i like to come over and be like i'm
sorry it's my granddad
poor old toby smith was just absolutely
told
they probably gave bitter advice to
other blokes than he did to me
oh it's classic who's the fastest scrum
half in the team
all blacks yeah it'd be me
yeah have you got tj [ __ ]
yeah i know how competitive he is and
he'll say that he is but
deep down tj knows he definitely
and poor nugget this is slowly he he
tries to run as fast as he can but i
think he knows his limitations in that
area
okay how did you get into the otago
academy
uh i actually think i had to
write an application for it sure i had
to
yeah i'm pretty sure gareth and i were
at high school and we had to
literally write an application then and
we used to um
so we got in i was stoked like my
application was
uh was given and we so we lived
in unicol the first year big
uh building at uni for first years and
the
the academy training base was maybe
maybe a k
down the road so down down a little bit
of a slight gradient down
towards the university overall yeah and
so because
trainings would start at like six in the
morning um
before uni classes and stuff but i
remember in o week
so gareth and i went and bought a bmx
together we went halves in it and it had
like the backpacks
so we would we would bike we would dub
each other down
like so one time i would drive i would
ride the bike and he'd be on my back so
that would be comical sting like this
little guy on this bike
massive gorilla
so that would have been quite funny but
we used to um
remember no week we would um go and buy
like do you remember
bigfoots the the drink from oh yeah yeah
yeah
like like a script like a scrumpy but
yeah like a
bit of failure so we would go and buy
them the day before
knowing that we've got um knowing that
we've got
academy training in the morning we'd
have an academy bike down with our
bigfoots throw the bigfoots in like in a
bush
just out just by the academy thing do
our training come out and then like we'd
walk back and just
crack open it up and fill it and just
get on the pistol because we knew
everyone else
was starting real early like something
it's a terrible professionalism
instead of having a protein shake
bigfoot down there good stuff
and your first car had how did you buy
your first car and where'd you leave it
so that guy that i was telling you about
earlier
um the cider company yeah him and i um
him and in our second year we went
we found on trademe it was like this old
ford
fairmont ute from like the 50s it was
epic
it was like yellow with the sight it was
yellow
there's like green stripe down the side
bench seat it was awesome
we bought it for a thousand bucks for
500 each yeah we went up to um
to omaru to grab it and brought it back
and it was an absolute piece of [ __ ] i
remember we were driving around
got pulled over by the cops they had no
warrant for like ages
no registration yeah so the guy was the
guy was the guy was quite
understanding and he was just like right
i'll give you you know 30 days to get
um get the warrant and um that'll be all
good so
we went and sent it to the warren
fitness station it failed
just about everything
but uh but we loved it so we tried to
like we tried to fix it and tried to
like get it
roadworthy and then i was driving it out
to um
to the sharks for training and it just
like
[ __ ] out like the clutch blew out like
like it was just gone and so i just had
i looked
he just like drove it to the side of the
road just parked it there walked
walked the rest of the way the training
and then just left it there and then
i don't know what's happened to it so
it's still there
well i had i made one of my mates
pulled up into a into a gas station and
saw it on the back of the tow truck so
some
someone got it towed must have just
taken it to the scrap
to the scrap yard and give it to the
scene again oh that's good stuff
okay oh advice you'd give a young guy in
the same position you were in in
otago without a pro contract
um i'd say definitely do
definitely do more work outside of um
outside of your
your rugby trainings and do
particularly on your passing and kicking
just smash your skills but
also don't forget to have a good life
balance still have dunedin's a place to
have fun so
don't let that take over from being a
student
and having a good time with the lads
because i think that balance is
important especially in a place like
that
yeah good advice
[Music]
okay well that's the thing like i see
i feel very lucky because i've been able
to basically live two lives like
i got to be a student and be normal and
get to have all these fun times with the
book with
with my mates that aren't rugby players
down there and then became a
professional rugby player so i've
been able to have the best of both
worlds because these days you know how
they just come straight out of high
school
yeah straight into like super rugby it's
like it's like great
great for the moment it's cool but they
don't get to experience being
being a young adult being being a kid
you know like yeah and having a bit of
fun so
yeah i feel very lucky but certainly had
some fun
oh yeah oh yeah
okay have you ever contemplated a career
in acting or voice-overs
no i have not but if someone wants to
employ me in that area then i could be
very interested
seeing through what you're talking about
who was asking that question
[Music]
okay i like how my videos just had a
really i love how my videos just had a
real
good effect on a lot of people yeah you
know
might have been a springboard for life
after footy potentially all down to one
bird
that's crazy yeah when you like actually
put yourself out there and do something
or like be yourself
like who you actually are in front of
people
amazing what opportunities can come
especially when you're
when you've got a status like you do in
the all black
side i just think there needs to be so
much more that so many guys are
too scared to put themselves out there
and they're missing out on opportunities
like this look you could be a
professional actor next year
exactly but that's the thing like like
we we know how
good led's personalities are in our
rugby teams that's why we love it
um just so programmed to be robots with
with the media and stuff so
like yeah it is encouraging to see
probably a little bit more
especially with like stuff like this
generally like every podcast in there
like
you feel way more comfortable being
yourself around like people like you
than you do with
some bloke with um from stuff or new
zealand herald who you don't know
is really going to have your best
intentions like most of them do the vast
majority do but
some don't and when you get caught out
like that that's why you go into your
shell
so that's why i loved like sam coming
out
around saying like punters don't know
what goes on like
what goes on into the 80 minutes through
the week because yeah
yeah it's good stuff yeah and he got he
cocked heaps for that day but
so unnecessary like no one yeah no even
like i don't know i play professional
also done a bit of coaching for fishbow
but i don't know what's going on in the
all black camp at the moment i don't
know the details that
you guys are going through um and to
think that people at the pubs know
this sort of extent it's just yeah
crazy that guy's here yeah they're gonna
debate that
yeah it's ridiculous some people just so
hurt that
sam said that but they're only hurt
because it's
[Laughter]
oh that's true stuff um would brad take
a punch from ben
tamiya foona if it meant ben stokes was
caught in the cricket world cup
absolutely i'd take it 10 times over
heartbroken by it still can't get over
it yeah
[ __ ] you just want to see a
qriket world cup victory in your
lifetime hey and i you just hope
that that wasn't that i'm sure it won't
be our only opportunity but
some game oh
i was there that we were you i wonder if
you
were uh for the cricket ball cup
semi-final in auckland
no i wasn't i was in japan
tojo might have been there potentially i
was with i was with whopper
you know yeah it would have been yeah
can i probably just finish
yeah yeah that was probably just walmart
that would be the warm-ups with tojo
like i would have been a beard
[Laughter]
still still probably the greatest
drinker i've
i've played with your brother hurricane
is he
he's right up there well he's
[Laughter]
i was there at that semi final and it
was like seeing grant elliot hit that
six was honestly quite possibly the
greatest feeling i've had in my life
like it's right up there with when
we won the shield like that same feeling
of just yeah
yeah was something that was some moment
eh
yeah okay
we'll crack on has he ever sponsored a
radio show
not officially but
unofficially i sponsored head heart and
balls from the tib
oh steffy and ant was going back
it was just a running gag like they
would
somehow mention me in every single show
and just like call me like sponsored
like
that i've paid to be a pigeon because of
your poor gambling or
yeah exactly that's why i have to give
up the punt
that's good um
okay how does fire to tackle
oh i can uh white suck in a hole i was
always the hardest for me because
like i just i remember just getting full
thrown off him
in a game against him in dunedin when i
was it might have been 25
2015 year but like he's a guy like
you can't give him the outside because
he'll just
run around yeah yeah but then when you
get too far in front of him you think
he's going to stick you and you're ready
for that and then all of a sudden he
just
full fiji and defends you and just bumps
you off like
[Music]
yeah just a hard man so yeah he was
always he's always tough for me i was
i was happy when i saw him go to go to
europe
your granddad wouldn't have been too
happy with that tackle attempt either
would it
yeah that's that's probably what sent
granted over the years to be honest
that's probably
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm sure he's laughing up here with us
yeah he's a good man
um if you had to share a room with
someone
who would be the worst this is an iso if
you had to share your room in
iso who would be the worst fallback to
have to share your rumor
the worst all black yeah currently
current comparing all black
um probably
i've heard uh heard stories about
um nipple laulala apparently
loves like having the room like freezing
cold
as the air conditioning goes i
apparently likes it freezing and
like i'm not about that i'm good at room
temperature you know sort of the 22s
21 degrees yeah i can't have anything
sitting at 16
for two weeks
four nights my mate neeps um and after a
few years he's a scary man so
just take away from me fair enough
cold room and scary
okay last question best do
yes too you would have had that many
this is going to be a
tough one what code
code do i assume this is probably
meaning oh
you can take it where you want
um this code do would
um would be my week would be the week
after
um we were on the shield like i was
talking to you about before like oh yeah
we were we thought well we thought we
were the kings of the city i always
thought we'd run out we would take the
shield everywhere to every pub and
um i remember when damien was
where me and damian were riding around
on beaver's golf car
around the road like the road of tuna
suburb
pretty hammered which is it was shocking
looking back but we thought
i was on the back with a shield like
this i wasn't driving past just tuning
out
but absolutely shocked and looking back
on it but like it was good times
and then um and then non-rugby you do
it's been a few
um
it could be any one of the lochens and
dunners but actually um
the race the christchurch races last
year
right up there we had a hell of a crew
great spot
and just just charged like we just got
back from the world cup so
did you do the week tuesday this year
for a week yeah
we did the did the full week so just
one of the great weeks we played golf in
between and um the tuesday and the
day thanks dreams
where they what and dashed too
[Laughter]
things were absolutely crushed
by the nose of some horses whom god said
how good wow what a story
some yarns in there i honestly really
appreciate you coming on the
wallet podcast it's been awesome to see
you doing the things that you've been
doing i've been
following your journey for a long time
you're an absolute champion bloke and
um it's awesome seeing you get some of
the respect that you
deserve not only on the field but off
the field
looking forward to following your career
not only in rugby but
um either djing acting
wherever you take it mate you're going
to be successful whatever you do
so i'm really looking forward to
following your journey and yeah
appreciate your time mate
no mate thanks for having me on and it's
been an absolute pleasure
um getting to know you and your brother
as well actually
two absolute top lads so uh choose
having me on jimmy your
top man thanks mate appreciate it sweet
right